大家要去收脑子里面看我们这个海报哈，然后下周的周六周日希望能在线下见到大家，很紧急啊，曹老师。
很紧急，很紧急，反正我觉得就是西安坚守吧，也许我们就是凉了呢，也为何知，也不是也不是，高内出示给谁啊。
大家好，我已经回来了，安庞康败康，我从欧洲回来了，我现在已经完全是不一样的自己了。
哎呦，你的欧洲名字是？
22个小时没睡觉，我跟你讲，从天上飞，飞的那半夜天空中后边那位姐们在那大发雷霆。
为什么？
说，你过来，你过来，管人空间叫服务员，怎么现在还有人管空间叫服务员呀，真的很恶心。
很多这种都祸，然后上来就看，真的真的很恶心。
然后说，你看我这窗户，找火了，告诉我特别特别热，啊，晒死我了，哭哭毛毛热气，人说那我给您遮一下吧，没有用，那我说给您拿个冰水吧，那有什么用啊？
说那您的宿舅是什么，我就告诉你，就很热，我差点说出，我说你把它拆开，我给你窗户打开，兜兜风啊。
哎呦，我跟你讲我现在，我从这个欧洲一回来，我整个人完全的零质大开，我全通了。
你现在随便提问，我跟你讲，我现在对这欧洲的了解程度甚于对于你们家这个客厅了解程度。
你这一趟去欧洲，你先跟大家说一下你去了哪几个地方？
你就这么说你激动不激动？
我为啥激动了？
你的朋友去欧洲了呀？
但我没去呀，但我其实很羡慕。
高贵FM现在正式接轨，变成国际的International podcast。
我们因为为什么，因为咱们现在有一个主播已经出过国了。
我也出过国了。
泰国不算。
但我确实没出过亚洲。
啊，真的假的？
我没去过日本，我去过日本，去过泰国，去过那个叫什么？
越南，然后还去过哪？
马来西亚，蒙古，但都是在亚洲。
对，我没去过欧洲。
最大的挑战就是这飞机，太累了。
要坐很久。
我回来这一趟坐了18个小时飞机，你看得出来吗？
我18个小时坐着飞机。
我跟大家说，曹福贵这个人多吓人。
早上我跟他说，我说这周咱还没录呢？
8点45分，我说要更新了，怎么一更不更？
8点45分，我说咱还录不录？
我说现在10点31分落地北京，11点半到你家马上录。
他说好啊，那明天几点？
我说今天，什么明天，经典。
然后跟我说22个小时没睡觉，
我说那你确定你OK吗？
他说，开始啊。
清醒令人堕落，只有微薰才是人生的真理。
我现在金句贫出了。
你说，你对于欧洲，对于这个最大的期待，
不是，你说经历了几个第一方。
我告诉你，第一站，咱们从北京出发，先落地哪？
法兰克福。
哦，法国。
从你们这枪崩了你，德国法兰克福。
哦，德国法兰克福。
法兰克福是德国。
我这文盲又暴露了。
你让我一直以为法兰克福也是法国。
我以为是法国。
不是，去了之后发现是德国，为什么？
安检的人谨重眉头，而且他没眉梦。
德国人都没眉梦，特别严肃，然后啪啦啦的。
德语李女士给咱们出的这个证明，相当的详尽。
生类俱下，可以说是现代的德语出示表。
里边写了说我一个人，只身来到海外，独自求学。
8月18号是我的生日，我极度期待我的一个朋友，
与我共度我的生日。
看完之后那签证官哭了，暴斗动哭，
然后说，阿辞斯古特。
啪，过关，咱就过去了。
阿辞斯古德，来现学阿辞斯古德什么意思？
一切都好，阿辞斯古德语说，你先重复，
阿辞斯古特，不是特，是特特特德。
对，阿辞斯古特。
哎呀啪，咱就过关了，其实人家没有哭。
然后我从法兰克福要转机去阿姬斯特丹第一站。
为什么？
李女士说了，下了飞机十点半，
挺博日的
咱们要看什么？
色情表演
小粉相
这个我提前听你透露了。
说这第一站下了飞机转。
一大早要干嘛去看色情表演。
咱们得看看这欧洲。
李女士的形容非常准确。
叫专属于欧洲人的变态。
为啥呀？
搞说她就说欧洲人的这次表演吧？
但是你也别太期待了。
我跟你讲 朋友们。
为什么？
因为咱们没看上
咱们为什么没看上。
此行同行的不光有我和李浩远。
还有李浩远的爸爸妈妈。
大姨大姨父
但是你去那你发的那个视频。
我跟大家说一下
就曹老师给我发来一个视频。
他们走在一个那个像是。
蜡巷馆一样的地方。
然后就有很多那种欧洲男的。
那种那是性不稳
然后男的突然衣服先开底下。
哎呦 厉害
对对对 我跟你讲这个。
因为我们去了那个阿姆斯特丹。
他称之为欧洲性都。
你知道吗？
你说的乱不乱套
荷兰
曾经的海上霸主的。
海上马车夫的国家。
是向第一批富起来的。
你知道那份他们
公费开支去抢劫呀？
人家那个国家鼓励你去当那个海盗。
你不知道
我不知道
你知道那英国女王那会儿。
谁要出去杀人杀的多。
给你奔勋章
谁要出去抢人抢的多。
你看这小哥谈现在。
还是不行了
英国有自己的高士造调。
我跟你讲那个时候呢？
因为荷兰是第一批海上马车夫。
他早就富了
所以他封的厉害
所以他后来他现在就是把他那个。
荷兰的首都设为了。
这个大马合法
以及这个红灯区一条街合法化。
你以为红灯区是什么样九尺肉林。
不是
人家里边全都非常的正规。
我们现在也有啊？
我们现在那个吉祥村。
笑话
你过来就要一个
你舍个花
一样的呀？
完全不一样
给你讲
不是
我跟你讲去了之后呢？
完了你荷兰人他封的厉害。
他确实有点封
然后其中之一我们就去了那个性博物馆。
性博物馆据说在荷兰办遍地都是。
我们就随便进去
30分钟速战速决。
因为我们去的时候正好赶到了那个pride。
就那八月
游行
就是那个LGBTQ。
ZWXYZ
3Q2Pi
等下后面
后面就是64个性别吗？
那我买Solidar也是一个性别。
你又跟不上
我给你讲我现在完全都欧化了。
我现在没有我给你讲。
他们那边就是现在搞那活动的。
所以他们那边就搞这个正好赶着pride。
然后他专门在那个性博物馆里面。
列了一个斩层
就是男的和男的女的和女的。
有
这么一个斩层
但是呢？
最精彩的不是在这个斩层。
在这一进门
然后李浩语说
你老婆找你有事
我说什么事
看那个小壁壳里边。
有一袋帽子
穿一大封衣的
就很像那个富尔摩斯的那种装扮。
你
然后他那个
他专门里边还有装置。
你知道吧？
他说
我说什么事
还是亮着红灯
你假人啊？
你假人
然后你一走进去
说什么事
这个
他跨把那衣服一打开。
底下一丝不挂
底下一个大茄子那挂着。
而且做的非常的逼真。
我感觉偷门有人摸过。
他发亮了
你看没看我那半天。
有人说你没扔硬币吗？
没有
就是说他那个博物馆里。
展出了各种各样人类的。
社会的性行为
然后各种各样的这种。
比如性经历
比如拿皮鞭的抽的。
然后还有好几个人。
在一块打仆克吧？
打仆克
互联网用语
明白
对
反正他们就是各种。
展示
然后我就看了一圈。
哎
大同小仪
我觉得都那么回事。
没还记得
我觉得我已经见过。
太多大风大浪了
没在那里边见
但是我有一个
我觉得那个是真是人间精品。
说说
那个水盆洗手盆
那洗手盆我给你发那照片了吗？
洗手盆
然后呢？
那洗手盆
那洗手盆全是丁丁洗手盆。
这一圈全是这个
我觉得这个是真是艺术品。
他如果卖那个
这个丁丁洗手盆的冰箱贴。
你想必是要买一个回来。
哎呦
你还说这个呢？
我路过这个阿姆斯特丹丹红灯区的时候。
我特别想买一个木头的。
这个
泰国什么的
那些很多卖这种的。
那是吗？
我当然没有去
但是呢？
我就特别想买
因为崔雷有一个
他就是人间去阿姆斯特丹的时候。
给他带了一个
他去过
我就觉得说
这个是一个纪念品。
而且这东西你在淘宝上搜。
你只能搜出来
这是人用的
你搜不到能摆在那的。
你知道吧？
就是你只是想买一个艺术品放在那。
对
你不想买一个这个实用品的东西。
然后完了之后你就搜不到吗？
我就很难受
而且我当时在那个。
错过那个店之后
我在淘宝上搜搜就是说。
你找不到关键词
明白
你打什么呢？
你打什么都不太对。
确实但我觉得这个东西就是。
一定要你去当地旅游。
然后买比较有意义。
你上淘宝买回来摆家里也怪怪的。
可是我就走在那个地方。
我就没有办法进那个店。
很多我都想看
为什么？
因为咱们跟四位长辈一起。
四位长辈一到了红冬期。
已经如临大敌
党员的党庆马上录出来说。
赶紧走
走
万千走
别看万千走
那咱们该干嘛来了呢？
咱们来这干什么来了呢？
我是跟你讲
完全跟你想象的都不一样。
就是它就像是一个夜市。
明白
但是所有的就是比如说。
元素都是跟这个相关的。
它里面是有明确的性工作者的。
然后这些性工作者。
他们是在那个玻璃窗子。
玻璃门后边
玻璃门里边
展示的
对
有一姐们给我留下极为深刻的印象。
裤衩背心发光
他那裤衩背身发蓝光。
我说这裤衩背心
就基本上就是两块布了。
明白
然后整个人的体现。
出击一种什么？
就是说很自如
它不是说你想象的说。
哎呀？
它如击似渴
然后得着你叫挣你的钱也不是。
因为人家就这么在那后等。
反正就是正常展示。
很像凯德山
我就理解安娜温托尔为什么讨厌凯德山了。
因为他们的美学特别像凯德山。
大后嘴唇啊什么之类。
反正那个装造啊什么之类的。
但重点是什么？
我马上就诞生出一个想法。
说不出来
他们会不会是大学教授。
很有可能
因为呢？
你这样
因为你这样
因为我在去之前
我就读过相关性的。
了解过
就是了解过他的一个情况。
就在荷兰这个国家的一个情况。
就是说你再精英
你大概可能挣钱也不会太多。
如果你是普通人的话。
因为他像北欧这些国家。
他的评估差距比较小了已经。
你再穷
国家每个月至少给你发1000欧的不住。
所以你知道在这些国家的。
很多人宁可不上班。
因为他最多上班2200欧。
还不如领不住的
然后一不小心升之加薪了。
扣税扣得更多了
还不如原来拉得多了呢？
天哪
所以那这就是他的社会的一个情况。
于是我之前就了解过一部分。
我突然之间就有一个想法。
就是说这些比如说在。
阿姆斯战争性工作者。
他会不会
这只是他的生活中的一部分。
第二曲线
他是他的
你这词从哪学的
你因为晚上在抖音上看到。
那种大厂的那个什么？
让我说的第二曲线。
对
就是他会不会有可能。
是他的第二兼职
我就搜了一下
还真有这事
荷兰曾经的一个
就是在银行工作
工员
白天在银行
跟人家做这个就是银行的业务。
晚上没事的说
你说说你想法
哇
好酷啊？
我也说不出来啥
我觉得个人选择吧？
我跟你讲真的是个人选择。
因为只有在这样的一个背景下。
你才会觉得性工作者。
不是被剥削的
因为他是正常在上税。
然后这个街区里边。
政府还会组织体检。
并且他们会有严格的一个。
流程规范
就是你在接待什么样的。
客人的时候
你应该有什么样的安全测试。
然后你应该在什么样。
就是他会有一个安全规范。
还有一个很重要的部分。
就是在这条街上
你是不能拍照
不能录像
然后的话
保护人家的隐私的。
对
还有一个就是
他们一定会在玻璃门后边。
如果你没有跟他交易。
他不会突出来拉你。
他绝对不会冲出来。
这个咱们必须就要提到了。
跟巴提亚完全不一样。
巴提亚会上街懒恶。
我的妈呀？
我跟你讲
我
因为你知道
因为我之前没去的时候。
李豪月会觉得
我可能会在那非常震惊和错恶。
但我跟你讲
你去过巴提亚
你就知道什么是正规的。
什么是正规的红灯区。
就是
这个
就是他还是会跟你保持一定距离。
他不会突然冲过来。
或者是他就在你面前。
他不会拔了你
对
他不会在你面前
但你知道
我当时在泰国的时候。
我感觉非常非常难过。
我非常难受
就是我觉得
就是一种
哎呀？
就是那种
乱了套了
乱了真的乱套了
当然
你只能从观察者的角度上。
你并不是在说
我们这个社会
或者说我们这个国家。
我们将来
肯定不是这个意思。
而是说你知道
外面的那个世界
他们是有不同的规则。
然后他们不同的游戏的方式的。
而
最根本的就是说
你对于每个工作者。
他是不是尊重的
他的这个保障是不是健全的。
然后我就给高老师发了。
高老师以为我在胡扒道呢？
说这些人他们游戏。
因为他工作
我给他发了一个
就是那个
那几几年以简门
白天银行上班
晚上之后
发现他在那
红灯区就兼职
然后后来好像就是因为。
但是并不是因为
他这个问题
而是因为他的工作。
属于是比较偏
政府或者公务员那种。
所以呢？
会有一些压力
那我提问
就是这个李浩月的爸妈。
还有这个什么二姨。
大姨
他们他们提前
是不知道你们要去这些地方的。
你问的好
其实他们是想看一看的。
但是
介于你们在他害羞。
但是大姨始终在问一个问题。
这都是合法的呀？
这个问题问了五次。
他大姨是想干嘛呢？
可能就是想举报吧？
因为你知道在那个街道里面。
灯光酒绿嘛？
然后他大概就是
人非常地多
你知道你
你完全可以想象就是。
像那男老鼓像
对对对就那样
就那样
你就想象男老鼓像那个。
那个奶茶店
不宜十一的时候
那大家共男老鼓像。
对对对
那个什么那个奶茶店。
你给他那门头装坏一下。
里边站俩
那个三点女郎
对三点女郎
完了之后完之后
以前三里头
那跳钢花舞的不一样。
后来
我被整改了
取立了取立了
反正就是那样的
你知道吧？
他也是一个商业街区。
但你知道在比如我们上一代人。
或者比较大姨的眼里。
这就是人间地狱了。
这已经乱了套了
这已经跟
这撒旦
这已经跟这个当众。
那啥已经没区别了。
但那是因为大姨还没去过意大利。
到了意大利
有那当街卢管子的。
你把
咱们也看见了
咱们这一期是不是在试探。
这个中文多课的尺度和底线在哪。
咱们一看
那意大利好家姨先生。
导管子
街头导管子
就当街
当街
在大街上
我必须说这我们西安也有。
也有
但你们西安一定没有另外一个场景。
他的朋友都在支持他。
在旁边喊加油
是
我们去了
想想想
这意大利还是不一样。
这意大利还是不一样的。
炒票跟大姨一个立场。
一定是生气了
你不接受不了了
因为我们当时去意大利。
也玩之后
李浩月走过了一个车站。
就跟我说说你们还看见了吗？
我一直在给你识颜色。
我什么东西
他说你没看见男的在这。
导管导管的吗？
我说导管啥
他在那库当里忙活的吗？
我说没看见
他说有一帮人应该是喝了酒了。
成为了一个
就是说反正今天没事吧？
给他助威
对
今天咱们就来
就就是你了吧？
反正这么一个
我说有这意大利
还是确实不一样
乱套
这才是乱套
所以再扯回来
就说荷兰那一处
他还是比较正规
然后大姨经常问
比如上一代人经常问。
这都是合法的
这都是合法
但这个男性在街上这样。
这是不合法的吧？
这应该
那肯定不行
妨害治安
因为你不上睡
你还是没有参加
不找我上给谁去
你还是没有参加欧洲的逻辑。
我已经理解了
你干什么都行
但你必须得交税
你懂吗？
你我跟你讲
这欧洲人穷的
我就送他两个字
惊穷了
哎呦
你知道我在欧洲始终。
就履履回想出
回想起一段写在红楼梦当中的。
雪宝拆
这不是雪宝拆
是探春说的一段话。
什么？
说我前日里去他们原子里。
他们原子还没咱们这个原子大。
才知道
哪怕是鲜花
一个草芥
都是值钱的
哎呦
我跟你讲着
这欧洲什么都是值钱的。
就是所有东西要收费。
上厕所也要值钱
也得收钱
这我又说二文一欧一次。
一欧八块钱
你买瓶水是三欧三八二四。
二十四块钱一厅可乐。
在那上一厕所八欧。
什么都要钱
你就去
咱们就正经了
你比如说去了那个博物馆。
正经的那导栏
比如那纸片导栏
应该白送吧？
对
我刚才不跟你开了吗？
就是那个
大家如果去什么故宫干嘛的。
里面有那种小册子。
咱咱咱那儿就随便放假。
他自己拿的那种
这个就是两欧
这小小小保纸片子。
我现在给高老展示。
这欢迎来到某某某地。
历史和幽兰
如果你想拿到中文的。
当然其实什么语言都一样。
有中文英文法文德文。
什么这那意大利文的。
日本的
你拿一个就抄两个钱。
你按理来说
这破册子
它值钱吗？
它不值钱
它也要钱
还有更奇特
我这没给你找了
那语音导览
你叫那语音导览
要花
也是得要花4欧还是8欧。
你想要多少钱
30多块钱
对吧？
语音导览
给你有啥
你知道
给你啥
你都能想象
给你一个二维码
让你一扫
你花了几欧之后
它给你一个小包纸片。
那纸片让你一扫二维码。
让你扫完就用手机听。
就是这些都是要花钱的。
一切都要花钱
然后我就理解了
就是说
这些人们一直在说说。
国外人付费意识墙。
那确实
确实是这POCAS的。
它能养回一批人
因为你只要在欧洲走一圈。
你就会发现
我的妈呀？
真的你干什么都要花钱。
呼吸睡
你在这城市里只要喘气。
就要收钱
马上警察说
can you breathe。
give me money。
没有
我再宽张
是什么呢？
叫城市睡
我离开那个酒店的时候。
因为一般咱们离开酒店。
还完卡片不就没事了吗？
对不对
那人就一直在跟我说。
意大利人都有口音。
cddax
小费是吧？
不是
cddax
我是什么cddax。
什么大x
我是什么taxi。
不是不用taxi。
我是notaxi。
vrbass
vtribe
那个subway。
no no no。
cddax
我是什么东西
就是他们发音会把T发成D。
然后我就理解
啊城市睡
城市睡
我说什么城市睡
什么城市睡啊？
你们酒店什么城市睡。
你来旅游
但是你要给人家城市建设。
就是你交钱
对
你所有
你已经交了酒店费。
你还要交一个城市睡。
仅仅是因为你来到了这个城市。
他们的意思就是
你只要来了
你就得为这个事付费。
你要不然你就睡大街。
你要不然就睡大街。
也要交大街睡吧？
他们起讨的人好像要去发上上睡。
就是起债是个工作。
我不知道
我编的
我黑欧洲呢？
反正就是这些喊人都要花钱。
我就理解
哦这付费啊？
真的就是说方方面面。
都要让你花钱
你的一举一动都要花钱。
所以朋友们
这本期节目打赏就在底下。
你可以随便点
随时要了
说这期节目的目的在这。
对不不
我就理解说人家的付费。
所谓付费意识其实就是。
一种无处不在的济费。
什么都能按钱济费。
那我好奇那几位长辈。
对于这件事
他们是怎么评价的。
他们
我觉得长辈的理解还是蛮有趣的。
就是长辈的理解
就是我发现我们上一代人。
对于比如说欧洲或者这个所谓。
西方世界还会有一层。
比如他们是强国的律径。
他们会部分50%的言论。
会认为这是一种现代社会。
文明的体现
会认为比如说
哦还有
你走在大街上
餐馆是不能去上厕所的。
你不能去餐馆上厕所。
花钱呢？
花钱可以
所以你就什么都要花钱。
你知道吗？
就什么你都要花钱。
然后如果说你现在就特别急。
你马上就要
就是报份了
你马上就要爆炸了。
没人管
你也你也没办法
然后你就是我
中途有一段时间
因为我喝了牛奶加蜂蜜。
再加成汁
你是为啥
是因为去了那之后。
水度不服
然后突然之间那上午。
就有点肚子叫起义了。
要造反
你那么喝你肯定得造反。
以至于找不到厕所怎么办。
打车回酒店
我打车回酒店上厕所。
我以为你当街
没有
但是你知道他就很诡异。
诡异是在于
虽然听起来好像很文明。
上厕所是要花钱
对吧？
好像很文明
但是很多人当街
尿尿
是的
但是你知道他有一种厕所。
就是在阿姆斯特丹是一个铁片。
我给你拍了吗？
他是一个铁笼子
他是一个铁皮
你给你想象就是把油桶给他拆开。
把那油桶捡成一个S形。
或者捡成一个就是回还形。
就这种形状
你知道吗？
然后他就立在这个地方。
你就去那上
人就在那里边上
然后底下是漏空的。
也就是说你在里边尿。
或者什么这
完全能看得见
明白
然后走到那
那就是一股浓烈的欧洲气息。
尿骚味
对
因为我前两天刚看完那个张可。
他们的那个
我老婆他们也是刚去欧洲那边旅完游。
那视频里面
时长总共25分钟。
大概喊了七八次
怎么这么骚话
到处都是尿味
我大概
你走在什么天桥里面。
街头
还有一些地方
你至于我走欧洲
走时间长了之后
我本能的就会觉得说。
哎
我说这个地方很适合尿尿。
你已经具备了
这个欧洲人的眼睛。
你知道
你具有了一个
善意发言厕所的眼睛。
就说
你觉得这个地方应该是很适合尿尿。
国不前那边的花的。
而且很诡异
就是一方面
他就好像很文明
他要收钱
另外一方面
就有很多人在大街上解决。
这些东西
他们当地没人管
这是我很好奇的一件事。
不
他这个铁皮的这个东西。
就是市政府
哥在那儿的
对
我的意思是
你比方说你在街上。
你会闻到很多
明显是很多人尿
才会有那个味儿遗留下来。
他们当地没有什么警察。
或是治安人员区
据我的观察
我觉得是分街区的。
穷人区没人管
但是如果你这个地方。
比如说我们后来去了。
那个罗马的中间
就全部是那个
像奈尔
对什么那个左边是卡地亚。
那边是芬迪
对吧？
你不可能在这条街上尿。
你要在这条街上尿。
那肯定是分分钟来找你了。
明白
但是你如果
比如说走在一个平民区。
或者是一个比较穷一点的区域。
那这个区域就完全没人管。
他们就尿尿自由了。
对
比如说我最后一天的时候。
住在那个罗马的时候。
我们相当于住在罗马郊区。
我们从那个地方到罗马城里边。
4公里
听起来非常短
但是那个地方其实是罗马。
中心外面一点的地方。
那个地方就是居住率比较低。
而且底上已经完全被喷满了涂鸭。
那个地方你想怎么样怎么样。
你想干嘛干嘛？
小隔弹
对
那个地方完全就没人管。
然后那个地方就是一个。
比较破败的一个地方。
然后就是他
这个关于就比如说。
这个上一代人怎么评价他。
你就我就是
长辈们还是会觉得说。
比如说
不让公众人
在就是社会上的人。
或者是大街上的人进餐馆。
去上厕所
这是一个不合理的。
这是一个很合理的事。
他们觉得合理
他会觉得说
这是一个保护我的私人的财产。
保护我私人资源的方式。
我作为一个商家
我没有义务去承担社会上的这些压力。
我没想到他们居然会这样想。
这是他的想法
而是一部分的他的想法。
但是
也会有别人就会说说。
比如说我们
这个环境当中
对吧？
我们要向公众开放厕所。
那我觉得这是很正常的事情。
我觉得你在这条街上。
或者你在这个环境下。
我觉得有一个很不一样的。
就在这些细微之处。
他就确实是有社会概念上的不一样。
就是他的社会概念就是。
你是不是大家在一起。
就是你是不是公有的。
他确实会分得很清楚。
你比如说他的策划他就分得很清楚。
我是我的
不会有让你用
我觉得他的那个
人的差别
或者我们所说里面外面的差别。
可能就在这些非常细微的地方。
他好像是以金钱为计算的。
但是他其实是一种生活。
或者是一种现代社会理念的不一样。
然后我是觉得我们这一代人。
跟上一代人的区别就在于。
就比如说我们
比如说我
我就不会认为
就是国外的这些东西。
它完全是可取的
我不会认为它是完全可取。
或者它这些东西是。
所谓更发达的体现。
我不认同
我会觉得那是他们路径上的那种。
就是
选择
形态
但是我们这个社会。
它本身就是一个
共同富裕
咱们得共同富裕
你就像
你少跟我在这儿
你就像我们没有地方录制。
我就跑到
高老师这小发展赛工来录制。
我们
对吧？
我们共享这个空间。
我待会睡哪屋
是礼屋
我待会
你睡楼下
你看
他现在要跟我敬畏分明。
我们楼下也有尿骚尿。
你睡了
这小区也这样
就是说
我们这个环境
它是这样的一个环境。
它不是一回事
但我发现可能
比如上一代人
他可能还会有一点点滤镜。
就是说
他们果然是发达
对
他们果然是更文明。
更发达
更现代
但是他又很割裂
因为上代人突然
花风一转
又会说
还是中国好
你觉得他很割裂
你知道吗？
我觉得这个是两代人的区别。
我觉得这个区别在于。
就是比上代人年轻的。
年轻时代
他们吃过苦
他们确实那个时候。
国内的情况要远落后于国外。
对
但是现在我们在物质生活条件方面。
完全不落后于国外。
而且从很多方便的角度来说。
咱们确实比他们方便很多。
对
就是交通
来给你展示一张
我们的交通单据
你看看嘛？
咱们这张
这是一张地铁票
你看这地铁多少钱。
地铁二十五欧
二十五欧一百多了。
一百六的欧
这做多远
这个是本来它是一个两张通票。
两天通票
但两天再怎么做
这也做不了一百多块钱。
在北京也做不出一百六十块钱来吧？
你就是把北京的十几条件做变。
你就别说这个
你就坐高铁
从北京到天津来去一百块钱。
是
对吧？
然后我交通也很贵。
然后它就是
而且我发现在欧洲。
它有一个叫什么欧洲之星。
特快车
然后它一千多块钱的票。
他们那边打车是不是也很贵。
很贵
打车也很贵
这跟日本比呢？
比日本便宜
日本
日本更变态一点
还日本更变态一点。
因为打车在那边的话。
就是说你可以打Uber。
但是我也是在张可的那个Vlog里面看。
他们打车为了省钱。
打了一个那种最便宜的车。
上去的第一句话也是。
很臭
但是日本好像没有Uber吧？
日本所有的出租车都是政府的继承车。
我有点棒吗？
没有
我印象中我去日本三次没有打到过。
任何一次
不是出租车公司的出租车。
反正我去日本
就只打过一次车
是在京都
因为京都相对来说比较小。
然后我们去的那个地方。
我们就算了一下
它那个价格不是你要先付吗？
我们看这个价格
觉得ok
一百多块钱人民币。
我能接受我才打
不然我不舍得
我很怕他下来扣个几千。
我真的是会
我跟朋友在日本玩的时候。
最快张字打车
单次800块钱人民币。
一趟
大百八百块钱人民币。
也没多远的去
有多远呢？
也就从这到通州吧？
那确实很夸张
其实可能还不到通州。
你从我家打的天津也要不了800吧？
对
所以它日本还是更变态一点。
但欧洲的话没有打车没有那么贵。
但是它的公共交通不便宜。
然后公共交通不便宜的。
但是它不便宜就算了。
但关键它什么又破又慢。
又破又慢
然后就你比如说他。
你比如说他那个所说我们高铁。
我不知道欧洲好像没有这个东西。
他有一个叫什么特快。
但他那个特快好像也没有高铁快。
明白
然后如果你要做成绩之间的。
或者是那种所谓的。
他要分为两种
一种叫小火车一种叫地铁。
它不是一个东西
然后小火车是一般一般等地车表的。
然后地铁就是地铁。
明白
然后也很贵
那个那个玩意儿也不便宜。
但它有一个特点是。
欧洲之间可以跨国吧好像。
但我有点糊涂了
你知道吗？
因为我来回穿
就从德国周边来回穿。
我有点糊涂了
我好像没有做过跨国的那个线。
但如果你想做的话也是通的。
然后你在
还有一个就是它城市很小。
你知道有的时候
比如说我们从这个城到那个城。
比如说从科隆到
那北多芬故居在哪。
我忘了
我完全不记得了
然后我完全不记得了。
那个城之间做火车。
我感觉又20分钟吧？
就坐地铁吧？
20分钟就
那还好
很近你知道
就是从这儿到通州。
但它已经是两个城市了。
因为它很小
所以就是这种通动。
反正什么之类的这种。
那你这趟去
就是很多人都会说。
欧洲的治安的问题。
你们
我刚一下地让人抢了。
回来之后全被偷了。
真假的
当然是假的了
我们是什么？
我们可是六个人
六人成型的中国团队。
我跟您讲
我们为什么不被偷。
比那个唐僧
师都虽然还多两人。
你见过那个六个老太太。
比那个六王星吗？
我们就那么走
你说她这么偷
我们六个人三十一拉手。
三十一拉手
两个花叉着
走到那街上
所有人都看着
其实不是
我们防范意识非常强。
我去之前
这高寒实际地给我散布谣言。
我说我带个项链吧？
我说咱们去那个
意大利带衣内珍珠项链。
拍照好看
都说你这带着勒脖子。
我说我这不勒
都说人抢的时候勒。
他说人家直接从你脖那抢。
我一听我害怕
我以为那是天下大乱了。
我以为
但是欧洲有四大贼窝。
不是意大利
还有什么反正他们有四大贼窝。
罗马也算一个
然后那个
那个叫什么来的
就是那是弗洛伦萨。
弗洛伦萨也是一贼窝。
反正那几个就是贼窝。
但是我们没有被盯上。
所以你们这趟其实比较幸运。
是没有遭遇什么小偷。
完全没有
我觉得很重要
就是因为我们人比较多。
然后互相看着
再有一个就是包太多。
让人不知如何下手。
你比如咱们大姨拎了四个包。
省街随时带四个
四个大包
不是小包大包
里面干啥
我跟你讲
这就是你问到点上去。
我怀疑欧洲小偷
他能看明白你包里C的是什么？
因为他们已经习惯做案了。
他们据说有两个特长。
一个特长是能够一眼辨别你手势。
势不是纯金的
你带什么香奈儿
什么卡地亚人家看都不看。
那玩不值钱
但你若带纯金的
他跟杜金的事不一样。
上来就直接给你耳朵瞪掉了。
我夸张
因为过程当中
李浩月他主动把两个金的耳朵收起来了。
说这玩意他们能看出来。
然后第二个他们的特长。
就是他大概能猜出你包里是什么？
你想咱弄一个瑞士军刀盘的双肩杯。
C的鼓鼓呐呐呐
有一拉嘴没拉好
还一丘裤腿露出来了。
能偷玉和偷缩力很大。
人家肯定不想下手。
弄弄弄
大老远从中国背一条丘裤来让我偷。
里边丘裤我又是斜垫了。
回头弄两个轻烟滴丸。
你们塑腰就心细的话。
拉得一动一步
那他们有那没得卖。
就是可是
人家肯定让真心白银手机什么舞的。
是这种
对
然后呢？
你给包里装点那爱丘条。
没意到什么小偷
但是我跟你讲
就欧洲什么都收费这件事情。
充分证明的经济不太行。
是
肯定啊？
因为什么都要钱
你知道吧？
那经济好的话
哎你这样一说
那你看
你说有的人他有正经工作的同时。
他是去靠这个
那个那个那个
对卖卖那什么？
当第二曲线
对性性工作者吗？
你说这抢劫
会不会也是有些人的第二曲线呢？
我不知道
我白天上班我下班路上看见谁。
抢一抢一单我就走了。
不知道
但据说你在欧洲
比如说你遇到一些人。
比如说人家在那卖包。
你问他这包
比如说那卖那个LV。
对LV两千块钱
你问的是真的假的人说。
我没地方给你抢假的去。
都是从店里拿的
反正我没见到
就说哎我可以啊？
正常吧？
我没见到特别夸张的情况。
是定货起来
我觉得和你住在哪。
已经你是否有防范意识。
很有关系
因为我们大部分住的。
都是很中心的地带。
哎那你们这趟去那。
你们住的
而且人家
而且人家抽那个吸毒的。
每一公分强
人都在那车站哪
慢慢吸毒
你别打扰人家
你们这趟住宿环境怎么样。
挺好的
我觉得荷兰特别像日本。
你们是定的是民宿还是酒店。
都有
我最后一天的时候。
我们住在了意大利人家里边。
啊？
是LVNB上
对LVNB
然后他睡楼到我们睡里边。
不说吧我不相信
然后那个是住在
我们最后一天的时候。
住在意大利一个三十一厅。
但是那个就是特别像咱们。
70年代建的那种老房你知道吗？
他没停
你进去的时候全是房子。
他是那种房子
然后你有的时候看一些。
比如说欧洲电影
然后那欧洲电影里面。
那些人住那房子那样。
老房
但是他们老破晓
他们是三间连着的。
内室就是卧室
然后这三间卧室外面是一个走廊。
这条走廊串连的镜头是厕所。
然后这条走廊的左边是他的厨房。
然后这条走廊的那个镜头是他的大门。
而神奇之处你知道在于什么吗？
他们中间
每一间房间都有窗户。
因为它是一个很奇特的构造。
就是它在那个设计上。
让你这一梯四户
一梯三户
一梯三户户户每间都有窗户。
它没有一间窗
没有是没有窗户的。
这个还挺难做到的。
就是因为它是每一个就是能老设计。
那是他们那种比较经典的那种。
欧洲老一点的房子。
我们没有住太新的房子。
那是一老
然后酒店就是正常酒店。
那你们去这趟
就因为你跟这个比方说你跟李浩悅。
大家就属于同一个人出去玩。
其实相对来说会
没有什么太重的负担。
或者说差异了这种观念。
但是带着这大姨什么？
这些爸爸妈妈一起去游欧洲。
这听起来就
你又问到点上了
你真的很会问
因为这就是我最喜欢看的。
你想你没机会问你笨着那条事来。
你找那矛盾点
That's why I'm a coach。
你每次问
你每次问说
咱们饿不饿
不饿
咱们吃不吃
不吃不吃不吃
点菜
点菜就是都行
你点
我们吃什么都可以。
然后点完之后说
点完之后说
那个怎么不点一个。
对不是
点完之后说
哎呦
这个点的时候说吃什么都行。
但你问这个
就说都可以
哎呀？
但是你给它看的时候。
还是会点比较什么？
比较像中餐的菜
但是吃什么都可以。
但是最终还是想吃什么？
炸酱面
就是说
长辈们还是不太愿意表达自己的需求。
长辈就是很爱这个。
忠实家庭
哎呀？
不过什么都可以
但是最后还是会挑便宜的。
完了之后说
不用花钱了
不可不可
一天溜溜没喝水了。
不可不可回家喝
嘴都爆皮了
不可不可
饿不饿
不饿
早上就吃了
拌了拉苹果
饿的脸都发绿了
眼睛都已经
眼睛都已经失神了。
都要进急诊了
不饿
人都打话都不饿
我跟你讲
一天都不饿
点完了之后
呼呼呼
全吃完
咱曹老师这一趟真正的参加了。
这什么花儿与少年。
花儿与少年
第二季
好
那我现在决定这一期。
这一期放在小高的岛上发。
这样他没有听不着了。
我跟你讲
我总结了一个
经典的
中式家庭对话方法。
就是禁止对方做想做的事。
强迫对方做不想做的事。
是啊？
就是非常经典的
很典型
然后往往之后觉得。
当然也是一种爱了。
也是一种爱了
控制
然后的
你说的
然后我是觉得
就是这个过程当中。
很多很多这种交流。
比如说上厕所
喝水
吃饭什么的
全是这种
但是我发现
比如说人到了一定年龄。
也并不会因为
到了那个年龄就Let it go。
还是会不断的
按照一个惯性去发展。
这以后有经历
有机会咱们再说
但我觉得这一趴
不在欧洲文化型的。
这个住宿
那这一趴
留到三五七之后聊吧？
对
我跟你讲
想听的朋友们
关注这个号
想听经典中式家庭对话吗？
我们三五七之后
再敲不声
能给你说一说
好的
我还有一个比较好奇的事情。
是这一趟你在欧洲旅行。
你第一次去欧洲
除了刚以上讲的这些。
社会方面的区别
你对这个地方
留下最深刻的印象是什么？
留下最深刻的印象。
你真又是问到点声。
你说这欧洲人
我最后一站
我有几个城市
我真的觉得简直就是。
你要在那儿
如果你有条件
你应该在那个城市住上10天。
一个是东安
东安
东安是哪儿
我不知道
罗马呀？
为什么？
因为罗马的对家是谁。
千年又好城市西安。
你不知道
我跟你讲就是这样。
我世界上有两个城市。
我觉得就是说
你值得在那儿
常住
住上一个月
每天参加博物馆
你都看不完
除了东安
就是西安
一个是西安
一个就是罗马
因为西安
对吧？
非临博物馆
你世界
你这球就分两瓣
东西两瓣
东半球就靠谁
就是中国
日本韩国都受中国影响。
你要追根素颜
你最后还是得要看老中。
你还得看老中
华夏文明他的
你就六朝古都
十三朝古都
对
你得去西安
西安底下城落城
对吧？
City按着City。
City市场还是City。
随便盖个楼
挖个木出来了
我前两天
我昨天还跟朋友说。
我说你看五泽天时机。
刚刻的杯纹
前两年刚出土
什么概念
2000多年的东西。
昨儿刚挖出来
斩心
赶心
就是西安那个城市。
当然不是去了
如果我就特别感动。
说没有人不会按西安。
然后我这次去罗马。
我也觉得
哎呦
没有人不会按罗马。
到处都是古计
你随便走
到处都古计
但是我有觉得有一种。
非常强烈的那种感受是。
你觉得就是说
最强烈的感受就是说。
我们在自己的
这个成长和教育过程当中。
我们真的是受到了。
西方前一末化
非常深刻的影响
而我们自己不自知。
你在那的时候
你突然才会发现
哦 那个地理课本上那个。
罗马角斗场
就在你面前
然后你才会发现
就是说很多我们
曾经
死计硬碑背不下来。
也不能理解为什么要学的东西。
是他曾经真实发生过的历史。
和他文化脉络当中重要的一个部分。
就像中国人不会去使劲备。
谁常摆草
对吧？
中国人不会去使劲备。
谁造字
仓介造字嘛？
神东常摆草嘛？
对吧？
你也不会使劲去备。
什么那些重点的那几个历史时间。
因为它是你文化体系中的一部分。
但是在西方的那个部分里面。
我去了之后
我才感觉到
就是说作为我们
就是甚至中国人
别的人就不说
中国人
中国小孩
咱们这些人
你从小受到的很大一部分。
所谓世界历史的教育。
其实就是西方历史。
而西方历史的核心。
它真的就是发生在。
那很小的一个区域里面的。
一个时间
比如你去罗马
你就看到好多你学过的东西。
你知道的东西
然后你才发现
你今天的整个世界的司法体系。
中国的司法体系
它是建立在罗马的司法体系之上的。
然后你会发现
我们今天的市政体系。
它是在罗马时期
它就已经有它市政体系。
我专门查了
汉朝的时候
咱们最大城市西安。
30万人口
它那边100多万。
因为它有很好的建筑的技巧。
然后它有市政体系。
然后它包括它横挣爆脸。
它满足抢了
满足它财富积累
诸如此类
反正就是你会发现。
我们其实经历了非常多的教育。
它就发生在这个地方。
然后这个是我觉得。
就是在罗马的时候。
我觉得这个地方原来就是。
我们一直理解当中的西方的。
古文明的中心
然后所有的那些我们今天在讨论。
仍在讨论的东西
其实2000年前就在这发生过了。
然后你比如说这个。
参议员中一
打架
特朗普
拜登
斯比
其实人家那罗马那会早就那么弄。
你就理解了
它其实今天整个世界的。
某个程度的根源所在。
从这来的
对 可是你这样
我每一次去这个国外的时候。
我心下都很复杂
这样我去日本的时候。
心下也很复杂
你看那时候你会发现。
好像有唐朝建筑影子。
但你知道那是日本的东西。
然后你去欧洲的时候。
我心下也很复杂
就说你不能完全的觉得说。
这个东西是
你要去摩拜崇拜它。
你要去follow和复制它。
你要去享受我们是什么？
我们是中国人
我这个时候想起了。
王女士那句话
走到哪你都别忘了。
你是中国人
就是你在跟它的这个。
过程当中你当然也会。
很感叹说有它的这个文明。
它过去的历史是很辉煌的。
它的成就是很厉害的。
可是你很快你就会意识到。
特别不能理解
走到这个罗马教皇他们家。
在他们家的客厅
就是这个梵蒂岗
我的妈呀？
我跟你讲真的是
就是我当时进去之后。
真的就是两行大字飘在眼前。
什么呀？
凡知不能更凡胜而不能再胜。
就是那个东西
你知道那个艺术品多到万地上流。
你就万千走说
又对不起踩你脚了。
你看又你踩的是一个。
大胃的脚
阿波罗的脚
然后那边国家有人撞你一下。
你看
是那个什么那个
雅典娜
撞你一下
就是那些文物
那些古董
多的我真的不夸张。
看不过来
堆在院子里
他有一个
他有一个中庭
他有一个院子
然后那个院子
是没有折棚的
也就是说爆晒
就放在那
就搁在那
那些东西就放在那。
潘佳园
这潘佳园
就放在那
古湾市场
完了之后
像
我不发了朋友圈吗？
那个质铁饼的人
他是复课的
他是公园二世纪复课的。
质铁饼的人
你以为他应该在一个。
多么正式的大厅里。
他就随便放在那
他就在一个
很小的屋子的
一个脚上
我跟大家说
这曹老师每天发朋友圈。
他都是
因为他平常是很少发的。
去欧洲这一趟
他每一天都发那个九图的。
九公格
这个九公格
而且配了很长的文字。
很长的文字
然后每一条朋友圈下面。
李豪月都在底下发。
没人问
谁问你了
这是李豪月
最近的新口头禅
李豪月有两口头禅。
第一个是
谁问没人问
第二口头禅是记得住吗？
记不住闻身上
他自己心打口头禅。
然后完了
还有一个趣
那是他跟开心解学的。
然后完了之后
就是说
艺术品非常地多
然后画
哎呀？
你就是我
因为他那个
樊地刚有一条走廊。
是那个叫地图长廊。
地图长廊左右两边是。
他古代画的
这个地中海地区
乃至他认知范围内全世界的地图。
他画到大概
中国的地方
没到中国就停了
因为没有到过那么远的地方。
到最远的地方就是印度。
对于他们来说
那已经是东方的东方了。
所以他那个走廊两边全是地图。
然后那个长廊
就非常非常长
头顶上
没有一块白的地方。
全都画满了壁画
然后他那个画那个壁画。
大概那个逻辑
就是说
这个时间阶段
谁是画团的新星
谁是画团上的名人。
你就在那儿来一笔。
那个就成为你的荣耀。
所以呢？
有些当时时代很有名的作家。
或者创作者
他可能已经是非常有名的。
或者是小有名气的工匠。
可能只能在这么长的长廊里。
画一小脚
画很小的一幅
这个很值得看一下听说。
然后你就知道
拉菲尔有多么的厉害。
他画一大条
你就知道米开朗记录有多厉害。
两个大厅是他全画的。
也就是
然后教皇因为特别喜欢他。
然后就喜欢这些大师。
就专门腾出两个
空白的
把之前画的给抹了。
抹了之后让他再画。
那被抹掉那些人太可怜了吧？
他们就不值得被留下。
确实
然后我有点
应该是拉菲尔
拉菲尔是在他老师画过的屋子里。
又画了一遍
然后所以那间屋子里边的。
天顶上的那几幅画。
是他老师的
他的意思就是说
留下老师的这几幅画。
然后其他都是拉菲尔画的。
所以你进去之后
那一整片就是不一样。
然后你就知道他的那个。
你看比如这个
名声非常大的
像是拉菲尔
然后像什么米开朗基鲁。
就名声很大了
对吧？
那你去了之后你就知道。
这些原来在历史书。
或者你在纪录片
或者你在各种的东西里看到的人。
他的作品就在这
感觉是很神奇的
因为你之前
因为我一直对这些艺术品。
都特别感兴趣
对绘画
对艺术品都特别感兴趣。
然后我去的看那之后。
你就发现
这很奇怪
感觉好像有点去参加了。
线侠活动
见到你喜爱的伯伯伯主。
那么这一点的话呢？
太硬了
我们倒是那个
会做四周年的线侠活动。
欢迎大家来
对
就是在下周的
周六和周日
周六是在下午的6点到8点。
周日是上午的11点到1点。
两场活动的主题是不同的。
上次咱录的时候
还没跟大家说啥主题。
一场是聊工作
但是不是开内职场会议。
我们讲说工作
它应该成为生活的一部分。
和一种生活方式
然后另外一个是
做一个四周年的
相当于这个回顾
副盘
你以前听过那些
什么关于张斌的事。
后续
杨先生
对杨先生的脸
打了那个IC包了。
IC包到底有没有扩散的。
我们再副盘一下
这四年当中的精彩片段。
然后以及跟大家去交流一下。
四年当中
你有什么收获和变化。
我那海报画做得多好。
手机扣的
手机扣得相当有艺术感。
很厉害
然后这一期的收納斯里面。
还是会放海报
还是有大概一些名额。
你们想来的可以骚马来载。
来吧 朋友们
这能见一眼是一眼。
看一眼少眼了
这些年都去欧洲了。
明年很可能上火星。
早看一眼
晚看一眼
早晚看一眼
多看一眼
少看一眼
多少看一眼
来吧？
你上欧洲就学了这回来。
这打游师
完了之后你就说回来。
就说我在那个话听那个长廊里边。
你就突然觉得说
这些你曾经觉得
距离你很遥远
或者好像不是那么真实的东西。
它就在那放着
然后你也就知道
大师真是大师
真是不一样
因为我一直对绘画很感兴趣。
而且我在家的时候。
之前不是一直在看那个。
詹森艺术史
加特纳艺术同时
而且你画的也很好。
我说话是说
完了之后我去了之后。
你就知道大师是完全不一样的。
他们为什么能在那个时代。
成为引领时代和
绝对的乔楚
那是实至名归
就是说
因为你看了很多其他的画。
因为我在那几天
你刚才说哪个地方。
值得待会儿印象深刻。
才聊了这个
佛罗伦萨罗马
罗马就包含了那个凡帝纲了。
然后维尼斯
就这三个意大利
你看说的全是意大利的。
就是艺术品多得遍地流。
真的艺术品多得不得了。
你看不完
所以你看了好多天。
那些画之后
你会发现有种审美疲惫。
就是你对于欧洲那种古典工庭画。
或者是那种拜卵庭实际那种画。
你就完全疲惫了
可是你在这个时候看到。
这些大师的画的时候。
你仍然会觉得
他是百看不厌的
因为他在绘画技巧上。
就是很高
然后他在审美趣味上。
是领先时代的
因为他那个审美趣味。
咱们这就太深刻了。
咱们这个就太深刻了。
就是咱们这期节目。
因为主要跟大家
这审美趣味上
我准备在真实的人类单独录起。
有跑点引流来了
当然引流
为什么我跟您讲
因为我这一次对于整个西方艺术。
和它的发展史的审美。
履得非常清楚
因为我这一趟
我跟我那个同行的朋友一直在说。
他说你怎么会对这个画。
相对来说了解一些。
因为我历史不好
但是我又特别想了解欧洲史。
因为你会发现你世界史。
其实大部分很多人都在讲。
就是西方史
然后你西方史就是欧洲史。
然后你了解欧洲史的话。
我对于谁打仗
谁当皇上一点不感兴趣。
你再一个是艺术的。
所以我一直在用艺术史。
串欧洲史
一直在用艺术主史。
串西方史
所以我在那个过程里面。
就看了很多原来书里看过的东西。
然后你就意识到
就是说
在那个美学审美
它的那个层面上
它绝不仅仅是所谓的色彩。
绝不仅仅是所谓的。
好不好看这个问题。
它内核里面是
我们今天所说
就是它这个欧洲
或者它这个西方世界。
它所传达的那个不同时代的。
价值核心的观念是什么？
你看这马上掉行分。
咱们高国iPhone不一样了。
咱们去真实人类听吧？
所以我当时看的时候。
我觉得真的很震撼。
真的是很震撼
那个震撼是多维度的。
就是它在宗教的层面上。
给你宗教的权势
它在社会的层面上。
让你看到它非常先进的那个发展力。
然后它又在
人文的层面上告诉你。
它人文一幅星的时候。
它怎么从那神坛上走下来。
这些东西叠加在一起的时候。
你就知道
它是跨时代的
那个东西它所以才保留在那。
然后你就说到这里了。
所有那些艺术品多的不计奇数。
多的满地都留的情况下。
还要去埃及强
还要去别的国家强。
我真的很想问一问。
咱们欧洲的朋友
怎么这么想要
你要就是这么多了。
还要专门弄出一个管。
摆的全是埃及的木乃伊。
为什么你跟他们有这个连接。
埃及的事项
要
跟你一样想要
哎呀我去了之后
全场没有人说出我这句话。
想要
我去了那教皇那个就是那个。
西斯廷
我去了那教皇那个凡帝岗。
我说出第一句话
我觉得应该是前五古人和我来着。
而是我们家客厅将来就这么弄。
就这么大个就行了。
门两儿这么大就可以了。
对曹老师就发了那视频跟我说。
以后我家就这么弄。
就这么装
我说你想不想上天的。
你还是
就这么装
但是我跟你讲
你拿纯大理石去装。
社交要求的挑高得高。
你一般三分五米都撑不起来。
那挑高二十多米
以后我们家的客厅都那么装。
哎呀能不能过上这样的日子。
就看大家了
就得看大家的知识了。
你就靠这个播客
你想过上那样的日子。
我不玩
我看你是疯了
我们是现在东方强国。
我说不定人人都能注重大吊堂。
哎呀很有收获
哎呀打透
不过我听完你讲完这个之后。
我其实对想去欧洲的这个心情。
又变得更强烈了
你就去
因为我真没出过亚洲。
然后之前每次一想到欧洲。
你知道就是跟我能结伴的人都会。
说欧洲之安乱呀？
别去啊这种的
然后我自己一个人我觉得有点远。
但我这个
我觉得近两年我一定会去。
好身体
必须得有好身体
不然咱们六个人
咱们六个人四个发烧。
你没发吧？
我没有啊？
所以李浩月发了
没有
那是谁
就我俩没发烧啊？
所以那个叔叔阿姨和这个大姨大姨父。
接力棒发烧
那是不是养了呀？
不是我跟你讲就是累的。
现在我跟你讲讲我们的十六天行。
请说
十二点到家
两点睡觉六点起床。
每一天啊？
Everyday。
那他们能不发烧吗？
头六六十来岁
我跟你讲四位老人飘在街头。
走路路地
脚底没跟
我跟你讲上台间两个台间就得喘了。
那西方人见你们想说。
我昨天也能看见鬼。
叔叔脸的发黑
阿姨脸发绿
我跟你讲累就累就那样。
累一句话都说不出来。
还要拉着他们
点菜
到了中文餐馆都不说话。
直接就这么点
都说不出话
一句话说不出来
我跟你讲这么累
然后只要因为我们这十六天的话行程非常紧。
相对来讲已经非常松了。
但仍然很紧
很重要的一个原因就是。
因为交通不太方便。
然后还有一个原因就是因为。
老年人确实身体不惊折腾。
你要有我的话
还有一个很重要的原因是什么？
咱们赶上整个欧洲最热的时候。
佛罗伦萨维尼斯42度。
咱们在暴日暴晒之下。
11点出门6点收工。
最晒的7个小时
我跟你讲晒到什么程度。
皮都烤焦了
我跟你说我从来没有感觉到那么晒。
对呀热
就加上比如热
然后再加上交通表不方便。
这几位咱们这几位长辈。
就是有点日日日日不行了。
走到后边脸都发飘。
就大概这么一情况。
但是我觉得在这个过程当中。
我求证了一件事情。
身体是为真正的重要本钱。
经过了跟周周四个月的锻炼学习。
你现在好了很
我真的
我这一趟你知道最大挑战。
其实不是这种休息少而行动多。
最大挑战是来自于李浩悦。
嗯
这个车
天天打鱼大肉
哎呦
最多的一次点了4斤的牛肉。
啊？
4斤的牛肉
难怪你们要吃5万块钱的。
你要注意了
4斤牛肉可不是唯一的菜。
是一道菜
你才点了4斤牛肉。
然后那意大利人说。
啊有手
说
人家开发你吃不了吗？
但是我们全都吃完了。
4斤牛肉
然后有条鱼
一个大C-Fu的。
然后三盘面
还有沙拉
这只是众多当
众的一顿
一顿
哎呦我天呐
另外一顿就是这种大菜六道大菜。
不算主食不算菜
那那些老人们都吃得了吗？
吃
饿呀？
这一天走三盘都不能不吃。
吃饿呀？
你说我跟你讲
长辈们虽然说不吃不吃。
吃去了之后就开始吃。
饿得不行
完了之后
就这么吃
是最大挑战
因为你这样
我最怕
我过去你知道我最怕。
其实就是水渡无浮吗？
然后我这一趟不断的在说一句话。
你有言证
你上火了
你说李浩悦还是你。
所有人
李浩悦说我这肩膀疼。
我说你有言证你上火了。
然后阿姨说阿姨说我这嗓子。
这句话百事不厌
就是一定是对的
基本上人的大部分不舒服都是言证。
然后我其实以前出去玩最害怕的就是。
一个是累
休息不够
再有一个爆晒
还有饮水不足
再加上不吃菜
对
再加上一直吃肉
因为你叫西方人他就是那玩意儿。
然后我每一次你像我比如说去当时去青海。
还有去甘肃
我都是三天马上就开始嗓子发炎。
然后这一次我就几乎没有。
我觉得还是跟坚持锻炼很有关系。
而且体力上还是觉得很充足。
最害怕的其实像我因为我们这次有16天。
很害怕半斤生病
而且那个病往往就是什么内火外寒。
冷气一击
你要不然就是发烧了。
你要不然就是什么了。
其实你也不是什么具体的感染什么？
就是你抵抗力不足吗？
但是这一次我就完全没有这个事。
我觉得我抵抗力就是大大的增强。
这锻炼还是有用
路到此时23个小时没睡觉。
你能看出来吗？
看不出来
必须还是得要参与运动。
朋友们
其实也没有
我在飞机上一直在睡觉。
我都足足睡够了
但是基本上没时差。
大家要去收脑子里面看我们这个海报。
然后下周的周六周日。
希望能在线下见到大家。
你怎么这么累
不是
因为我怕他们不来。
咱们现在只卖了30张。
就是一场只卖30张。
单场
单场还剩40张票。
就是咱们一共不是一场70个人吗？
现在两场都是只卖出去30张。
很紧急
曹老师
对
你现在来护育一下。
我觉得
嗨
大家都是老交情了。
能来就来吧？
能看一眼就看一眼。
多看一眼
不是
这个我觉得一点不交集。
咱们几号
还有10天
但咱们已经卖了10天了。
咱们还出去30张。
不是 问题是这10天之内。
咱们的节目就放了一期节目。
反正我觉得就是新人接受吧？
也许我们就是凉了。
也未可知
也不是
高内出资给谁
不是
欢迎大家一起来
然后我们这一次线下活动。
还是会跟大家一起来聊。
然后比如说聊我们之前所说的工作话题。
还有一些我们四年活动话题。
因为一年在北京就办这两个次。
你知道还有一个很重要的原因是什么？
因为北京不行了
就是人少了
可能走了
对
可能少 可能走了。
然后我看了
很多朋友还是去年来。
我还来
就是反正我们今年就在北京。
就办这两场
对
不会再办别的
很多朋友上次我们发了以后就问说。
你们来不来上海
来不来杭州
深圳
各种城市
下半年我们看情况。
尽量走一走
对
这个量力而行
反正因为书
我的那个书到时候会有一些活动。
我跟曹老师可能会。
创举一下他的差率。
根据行程
我们来
你这样说出来
人家出版者同意吗？
别让他们知道
反正这个意思
北京的这两场朋友们愿意来的。
欢迎大家都来
然后总于是一年一度一个聚会。
你如果我说了这么多关于欧洲的行程。
你就没有点你大感慨。
因为我没去过
我现在怎么感慨
我现在当我说实话跟你聊完之后。
你最好奇什么？
我很想去
我想我其实好奇的是你这一趟下来。
一共花多少钱
我现在都不敢
很写实的一个问题。
都不敢算我跟你讲。
因为像现在吃喝整个这个过程当中。
还没算账呢？
你们是AA的吗？
还是怎么？
是大家吃饭什么的。
都要在军滩
所以比方说
提前估计吃饭吃了好几大钱。
处我住宿啊各种这些的。
全军滩
那你现在还没有拿到账单。
还没拿到账单
但是我在此之前已经花了大概1万6七了。
因为是路费和其他一些。
什么办什么签证来办这些钱。
主要16天其实很长。
对很长
半个月嘛？
对
我觉得16天
你这个我预测一下你这一趟花费吧？
我觉得你
三万多
事后对
可能还再补个1万5六的样子。
对对对
三万多一点吧？
差不多吧？
反正你也不是年间去越越去吗？
那三万多去趟欧洲。
我觉得也就16天。
16天对
16天呀？
而且你还这么难得的。
跟李浩月的全家一起旅游。
多新鲜的
确实
哦
高韩也去了
我们仨都在
对我看到了
我们仨都在欧洲齐聚了。
这人生不可多得的一件事。
我们仨是高中中学16年了。
跑欧洲聚会去了
什么概念呀？
什么是三星奇迹三王狼来朝啊？
什么东西
反正就是这个福祿寿。
三星都到了
哎呀？
很不错
这个过程我且回味呢？
然后我要准备把这些都树立树立。
再录录一些其他不管整理。
整理什么之类的
咱们有机会以后再聊吧？
好的
行
这期就到这里吧？
就到这里
下期我们来聊聊牛奶。
为什么是一部好电影。
哎呦
你少在这许愿了